this week 48 hours investigates the
kidnapping and murder of a girl in
colorado more than 35 years ago
jonell matthews was just 12 years old
when she disappeared in 1984.
the case remained cold for decades until
her body was discovered
in 2019 and police began to question
a new suspect 48 hours correspondent
richard schlesinger looks at how the
suspect
came to the attention of investigators
on july 23 2019 a crew
digging a pipeline near greeley colorado
discovered what appeared to be human
remains
gloria and jim matthews had spent nearly
35
years wondering what happened to their
12 year old daughter
janelle everywhere we went i was always
looking
for her it was 1984 just five days
before
christmas when jenelle vanished from the
matthew's home
the only physical evidence discovered by
police were a stranger's shoe prince
left in the snow shoe prints someone
tried to erase
using a garden rake right out of my
garage
it wasn't until 2019 that police were
suddenly
questioning a person of interest
hundreds of miles away
i humbly ask for your vote a former
candidate for
sheriff and governor in the state of
idaho
and a one-time resident of greeley
stephen panke
we had never heard the name before that
pankey said the same to
cbs affiliate kmvt i've never met
janelle matthews
but this indictment points to repeated
statements implicating pankey
by pankey himself he allegedly
volunteered
without being asked what he claimed were
details about
when janelle died he told police
not to give the family hope and he drew
up a list of persons of interest
with his own name on it he's a talkative
guy
but he's not a murderer pankey's defense
attorney anthony viorst
says his client is a true crime fan
who simply craves attention mr prankie
wanted to be a person of interest mr
pinky could have laid low
nobody would ever charged him mr panky
loves the limelight
and richard schlesinger joins us now
this is a shocker richard good morning
what's the what's the best evidence that
police have against richard pankey
well the the only physical evidence that
we know of is that collection of
footprints in the snow outside the house
the police
never mention that to the public but the
indictment in this case alleges
that panky told police about the the
rake and the footprints and
they're wondering how he would have
known that so uh we should say the
defense lawyer has a as an answer for
that
um but you know that's going to be a big
issue at trial
the talkative part i'm sure was not
particularly helpful to mr pankey
richard schlesinger thank you very much
you can watch richard's report the
kidnapping of janelle matthews on 48
hours
tomorrow night at 10 9 central right
here on cbs